let's bring in arkansas republican
senator tom cotton senator thanks for
being here brett good to be honest i
want to talk to you about all of this
and foreign policy as well but i want to
start with uh what you've seen out of
kentucky you're from a state that is
very familiar with tornado damage and
all that comes with it yeah brett uh
terrible storms starting in arkansas and
going across the mid-south and into the
midwest
we lost two lives in arkansas and my
visits uh over the weekend with local
officials the mayors the judges the
nursing homeowner that of the nursing
home that's destroyed
uh one constant refrain by her is that
they couldn't believe that more life
wasn't lost but thanks to the quick wits
and bravery um of our fellow arkansans
um we only had two lives lost which are
tragic from arkansas right there yeah
some of the but some of the uh scenes
you've seen from kentucky and mayfield
in particular is just heartbreaking so
my uh prayers uh and condolences go out
not just to my fellow arkansans but all
fellow americans who are affected by
these storms it's going to take a lot uh
to rebuild okay i want to turn to that
story you just saw out of the state
department and this
incident with this map and what does it
say about the administration and what
they're doing uh well it projects
pathetic weakness brett when joe biden
convenes a summit for democracy and then
he has a member of taiwan's cabinet
speaking to other democracies and they
cut the feed simply because it shows
taiwan and china in different colors on
the map i don't believe for a minute
that it was merely a technical issue i
believe that this is an example of the
president and the administration
kowtowing to beijing what we need to do
is stand alongside taiwan
help secure its autonomy and maintain
the status quo across the strait that's
been the policy of the united states now
for 40 years but beijing is the one that
is now threatening taiwan threatening to
change that status quo by force not by
negotiation here is josh rogan with
washington post speaking of brian
kilmeade's radio show
it's some technical guy in the state
department who like sees this guy put up
a map of taiwan was like oh wait a
second we didn't know about that cut to
commercial
okay and then then was like oh my god
what happened like the white house told
us to do it okay so it does speak to
something like a greater problem with
this democracy summit because you know
they were they wanted to include taiwan
but only so much eventually we have to
acknowledge that taiwan acts like a
country walks like a country talks like
a country it's a democracy it's one if
we're going to support it we have to
call it what it is it's a country
what would you do differently
well first off joe biden should
apologize for what happened someone
should be held accountable in his
administration someone should be fired
for what happened but joe biden should
apologize for what happened say it
shouldn't have happened and he should
make clear that the united states will
help taiwan defend its own sovereignty
that starts with significantly expanding
and accelerating arms sales things like
missiles and anti-ship mines helping
taiwan get its own reserve forces in
order making sure that taiwan is strong
enough that communist china never
attempts to go for the jugular there
that's the best way to avoid a war in
the hottest flash point in the war in
the world is to make it clear the united
states will stand alongside
taiwan's democracy i asked defense
secretary austin about this take a
listen
so what would the u.s do
if china invades taiwan
again you know we our policy remains uh
the same
our one china policy remains the same
we're committed to uh helping taiwan
uh develop and maintain the capability
to defend itself so we're going to do
everything in our power to help prevent
conflict
and dial down
the temperature whenever possible
so that last part dial down the
temperature you have china and taiwan
you have russia and ukraine there are a
lot of people in the country who say
senator we don't want to be in another
war any place and if there's aggression
how do you do that without getting into
a war well of course we don't want to
have another war anywhere in the world
we always want to try to deter and
prevent war but the best way to do that
is george washington said our very first
president is to be prepared for war
that's the best way to preserve the
peace and in both cases whether it's
taiwan or ukraine it's to enable
those peoples to defend their own
sovereignty their own territorial
integrity by helping them obtain the
weapons and the training that they need
to defend their own terrain and being
clear that we will not sit idly by and
tolerate aggression against taiwan
against ukraine that we will support
these peoples diplomatically
economically and militarily if we do
those things in advance and make our
resolve clear that will deter communist
china that will deter vladimir putin
last thing build back better uh seems to
be
running into speed bumps namely joe
manchin on on capitol hill where do you
see it and do you think democrats can
pass it before christmas
well i certainly hope not you know i do
give joe biden credit for this brett
last year or last month we learned we
had the highest inflation rate in 30
years he said he was going to do
something about it on friday he did we
had the highest inflation rate in 40
years now of course if we spend 5
trillion more dollars that we don't have
in this legislation that's going to
contribute to more inflation that's why
senator manchin and frankly some other
democrats as well have reservations
about this do you believe it's others
beyond senator manchin yes i do both in
the senate and in the house of
representatives it is insane to continue
to spend trillions of dollars that we
don't have when we have the worst
inflation rate in 40 years when families
are having to
work hard to make ends meet at the end
of the month
paying for gas paying for groceries
probably cutting back on the christmas
gifts for the kids we don't need
trillions of dollars of more spending
senator kyle we appreciate the time
thank you brett hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else